retour sur l'assaut du capitole le 6
janvier dernier par les partisans de
donald trump une commission d' enquête
parlementaire a été ouverte par l'élue
démocrate bennie thompson de vifs débats
au lieu appuyés par des témoignages de
policiers présents sur place
pour plus de détails on retrouve notre
correspondant à washington thomas
bowness bonsoir thomas que retenir de
cette première journée bien cette
audition a duré environ trois heures et
demie elle s'est ouvert sur une vidéo
compilant des scènes de violence qui se
sont déroulés le 6 janvier dernier lors
de cette attaque contre le capitole et
puis il ya donc eu ces auditions quatre
policiers qui étaient présents au moment
des faits on a pu voir beaucoup
d'émotion leur part que ce soit des
larmes ou parfois même de la colère et
puis ce qui ressortit surtout c'est la
peur qu'ils ont ressentie face à cette
foule de manifestants et coûté par
exemple ce témoignage d'un officier de
police qui était présent sur place pour
être honnête je n'ai pas reconnu mes
concitoyens qui ont pris d'assaut le
capitole le 6 janvier dernier
ni les états unis qu'ils prétendaient
représenter j'avais 25 ans et sergent
dans l'armée
j'avais été déployés en irak pour
l'opération liberté irakienne de temps à
temps je me suis porté volontaire pour
voyager sur des routes infestées
d'engins explosifs improvisés mais mener
des missions de ravitaillement pour les
forces américaines et alliées ainsi que
pour la population irakienne
pour la première fois j'ai plus peur en
travaillant au capitole que pendant
l'ensemble de mon déploiement en irak
avec l'armée américaine en irak
nous nous attendions à la violence armée
car nous étions en zone de guerre
mais aucune expérience dans l'armée ou
en tant qu'officier des forces de
l'ordre ne m'a préparé pour ce que nous
avons à affronter le 6 janvier il faut
noter qu'un certain nombre des policiers
qui ont témoigné ce mardi ont été
blessés lors de cette attaque que contre
le capitole l'un d'entre eux à
d'ailleurs déclaré j'aurais pu mourir à
plusieurs reprises ce jour là on a aussi
pu voir d'ailleurs une vidéo qui était
issue d'une caméra embarquée sur l'un
des officiers de police qui a témoigné
lors de cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire
on voit les scènes de violence contre
lui à ce moment là où ils crient même à
plusieurs reprises j'ai des enfants
comme pour tenter de convaincre la foule
de manifestants de l'épargné vers les
manifestants sont régulièrement
qualifiés de terroristes dans les
différents témoignages qu'on a pu
entendre ce mardi dans cette commission
l'un des policiers fait également
référence à cette attaque contre le
capitole comme d'une bataille
moyenâgeuse et puis un autre policier
indique lui avoir reçu beaucoup
d'insultés racistes lors donc de cette
attaque
il ya eu donc plusieurs questions de la
part des parlementaires pour tenter de
revenir sur le déroulé précis des faits
sur l'attitude et les propos qui ont été
tenus par les manifestants présents ce
jour là et puis il y à une question
principale surtout qui a été abordé quel
est le rôle du président donald trump
dans cette attaque il ya par exemple un
policier qui affirme que des
manifestants ont déclaré ces donald
trump qui nous a envoyé est évidemment
toute la lumière va devoir être faite
sur le rôle précis du président
américain dans cette attaque contre le
capitole il faut noter que la création
même de cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire a provoqué beaucoup de
débats ici aux etats unis puisque
initialement
les élus démocrates voulait constituer
une commission sur le même modèle que
celle qui avait précédé qui avait suivi
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 ça a
été refusé par les républicains et puis
donc lorsqu'est venu le moment de
choisir qui elle et lui allaient siéger
dans cette commission les républicains
ont proposé les noms et deux d'entre eux
ont été refusées par nancy pelosi qui
est la chef de file des démocrates à la
chambre des représentants
conséquence le chef de file des
républicains kevin mccarthy a décidé de
retirer toutes les nominations et
résultat est finalement il n'y a que
deux républicains au sein de cette
commission d' enquête parlementaire de
républicains qui sont déjà assez éloigné
de la ligne
officiel du parti puisqu'il avait voté à
l'époque en faveur de la procédure d'
impeachment contre donald trump alors
ces deux élus républicains c'est d'abord
liste chez né qui a déclaré qu'elle
voulait décortiqué minute par minute ce
qu'il s'était passé à la maison blanche
lors de l' attaque contre le capitole et
puis l'autre républicain c'est adam
kissinger qui justement est revenu sur
les polémiques qui ont entouré la
création cette commission et vous allez
voir il a aussi ressenti beaucoup
d'émotion au moment de prendre la parole
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que ce jour
soit aussi émouvant pour moi j'ai parlé
un certain nombre d'entre vous et j'ai
appris à vous connaître
je pense qu'il est important de vous le
dire maintenant vous devez peut-être une
sentir un peu brisé
vous parlez tous des effets auxquels
vous devez faire face et de l'impact
qu'a eu ce jour sur vous et vous avez
gagné vous avez tenu vous savez les
démocraties ne sont pas définies par nos
mauvais jour mais de comment nous
revenons de ses mauvais jours des
responsabilités que nous prenons comme
la plupart des américains je suis
frustré que six mois après qu'une
insurrection meurtrière est percé le
capitole des états unis pendant
plusieurs heures en direct à la
télévision
nous ne savons toujours pas ce qu'il
s'est passé pourquoi parce que beaucoup
de membres de mon parti on traiter cela
comme une simple lutte partisane alors
le lancement de cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire n'a pas mis fin
aux polémiques puisque kevin mccarthy
donc le leader des républicains
qualifient cette commission d'imposture
et plus de son côté donald trump
reproche à cette même commission
son manque d'impartialité il faut noter
qu'il n'y a pas de date de fin encore
pour les travaux de cette commission d
enquête parlementaire et qu'une audition
pourrait de nouveau être organisées
d'ici la fin du mois d'août et travaux
que l'on continuera à suivre
grâce à vous merci thomas bonne et notre
correspondant à washington